[Music]
what are the ten dragons that bonded
with riders that aren't targaryens well
first of all only people with targaryen
blood can bond with dragons that's for
sure but through marriages and mixing of
blood a few of them inherited that
capability and they were called dragon
seeds by the time of the dance of the
dragons there were a total of nine of
them including the valerians and other
bastards
bastard dragon seeds with their own
dragon mounds and yes we will also
include two other dragons that weren't
targaryen own and had their own riders
way before house of the dragon so let's
get to these dragons
number one sea smoke
bonded first with laner valerian the son
of the sea snake called as valerian sea
smoke is a dragon that is silver gray in
color and fought in the dance of the
dragons along the side of the blacks
which means the sight of princess slash
queen rhaenyra targaryen sea smoke would
eventually have another rider after
leno's death
being claimed by a bastard called adam
of hull who was later legitimized with
the name valarion
number two earaxx this was a small
dragon that was said to be five times
smaller than vegar but it was big enough
to be written by the time of the drones
of the dragons and was said to be
pearlescent white in color with a yellow
flame a golden chest and two golden eyes
this dragon was ridden by prince lucerus
velaryon who flew the beast as a
messenger since it was too small to be a
fighting size
number 3 tyraxis tyraxis was a very
thriving and fast growing dragon
although he was slightly smaller than
vermax and erax
his brothers by the time of the dance of
the dragons he had recently been able to
fly long distances with his rider prince
joffrey velaryon
but was not quite big enough for combat
and was chained into dragonpit during
the war and died there killed by a mob
number 4 vermax this was a very fast
growing dragon and was bonded with
prince jacarys velaryon by the time of
the dance of the dragons vermax was big
enough to ride so prince jacarys flew
north on his back as a messenger it is
said that vermax didn't like the coal or
snow or ice and became ill-tempered
because of it
this dragon saw battle in the gullet
the first time and died there in his
very first battle along with its rider
in the ensuing fighting
number five vegar this dragon was one of
the three dragons of aegon targaryen the
conqueror ridden by one of his sister
wives visenya
vega then went on to bond with balon
targaryen afterwards and then after
baylon's death vega found another rider
in lady lena velaryon so that's why she
is on this list and when lena wed prince
damon targaryen they flew on their
dragons across the narrow sea to the
free cities including pentas
cohort
lis miss whatever huge crowds came to
see and catch a glimpse of vega and
caraxies the prince daemon's dragon
number six silver wing silverwing was a
silvery she dragon originally of house
targaryen and was first ridden by queen
alison targaryen and later when she died
she did not have any other rider and
then when time went by
a bastard called off white during the
dance of the dragons came up and claimed
the dragon she was considered relatively
docile and friendly towards strangers
like another dragon verma thor which was
her dragon companion silver wing would
change size during the war and fight for
the greens
number 7 verma thor
also called the bronze fury he was a
male dragon first ridden by king
jaehaerys the first targaryen but after
his death he was claimed by a bastard
called hugh hammer
huge hammer
by the time of the dance of the dragons
verma thor was almost 100 years old
which means he was one of the first
generation dragons to be born in
westeros the bronze fury is said to be
the third largest dragon after vegar and
valerion
maybe fourth if we include the cannibal
number 8 sheep stealer this was a male
dragon a wild male dragon during the
dance of the dragons with a taste for
mutton
it lived at the back of dragon mount a
volcano in dragonstone and would hunt
between driftmark and when water
somewhere between the islands sheep
steelers coloring was an ugly mud brown
he was not aggressive towards humans
unless provoked he was one of the three
wild dragons in dragonstone and was
bonded to a bastard girl later on called
nettles during the dance
number nine terrax a young dragon that
was bonded with a female called genera
belarus a member of a valyrian house
that survived the doom
she and the dragon flew southwest to
sotherius a continent in the south which
was as large as essex as she said
so she returned to the valyrian freehold
after three years of traveling having
found only endless jungle deserts and
mountains
number 10 the last the unnamed dragon
not much is really known about this
dragon but what we do know is that it
was bonded with a valyrian dragon lord
called aryan who survived the doom of
valyria and he used the creature to
subjugate and control kohor one of those
cities in esses and he flew south later
on to lay claim to what remained of
valyria to be crowned as the emperor of
valyria and re-established a freehold
along with his 30 000 men from cohort
but then he was never to be seen again
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash the bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam